c'est donc été élue miss tahiti mais
avait déjà fait une tentative en avant
en 2000 brillance et elle avait été
refoulée même pas sélectionné donc à
sélectionner pascal avoué
qu'effectivement il avait lutté contre
contre le surpoids et que maintenant
elle était allée à les miss france on va
faire un petit récap en images par
trenet elle a été sacrée miss france
2010 9 devant près de 8 millions de
français samedi dernier
miss france 2010 9 mai tahiti
[Musique]
et pourtant vaille madame à chaves
nouvelle icône nationale a failli ne
jamais pouvoir vivre son rêve
en effet la nouvelle miss france s'était
déjà présentée en 2015 mais avait été
recalé au concours régional de miss
tahiti alors qu'elle avait perdu plus de
20 kilos pour l'occasion selon elle à
l'époque elle n'était pas prête mais cet
échec n'a fait que renforcer sa
détermination et trois ans plus tard la
jeune femme de 24 ans s'impose avec près
de 45 % des suffrages
une belle revanche pour la nouvelle plus
belle femme de france
[Musique]
évidemment indispensable celle là l'est
dès la rentrée des 5e et trois français
alors est-ce que ça me choque quand même
que on est un peu maintenant on apprend
surtout c'est comme le pmu on peut le
passer plusieurs fois le concours de
miss non mais c'est pas ça que les
choses dans ce qui est choquant c'est
qu'en fait il ya eu un standard on va
pas se mentir choqué à 30 mois à la
limite on peut dire que le fait qu'elle
ait été obligé entre guillemets de
maigrir pour être enfin couronnée miss
france c'est choquant en soi
alors elle elle le retour parce qu'elle
en fait une vraie aventure de vue une
aventure humaine et puis c'est cette
fille n'a rien de contestable moi c'est
le vote en lui-même que j'ai contesté là
c'est choquant c'est quand il se disait
que c'est choquant d'être obligés
d'apprendre à jouer au tennis pour
gagner roland garros faut bien répondre
à castanet christiane en beauté preuve
est contestable parce qu'ils ne
répondent pas ce que sont vraiment
l'effet nord à la salle n'est pas de la
femme mme vassal débat est la cible
d'une telle que tout le monde dise c'est
la mise des différences tout ça mais
c'est un très beau message pour les
femmes mais en fait c'est exactement
l'inversé comme en train de dire c'est
que côté est un peu ronde est différente
journal était mêlé pas sélectionneur et
que finalement la du père 24 kg et
revenir dans les standards vraiment de
la beauté aujourd'hui occidentales comme
on les aime pour pouvoir gagner donc au
contraire c'est peut-être le pire des
messages qu'il a voulu personne n'a
oublié oui mais le message de message
pour les jeunes la mise des références
et la miss qui ment sur les routes que
c'était différent dont les prix n'est
pas sélectionné jean-michel en fait
c'est horrible ça veut dire il a dit oui
c'est un concours de reine de beauté
c'est pas le concours de la femme
moyenne oui c'est au staff mais ses
propres ailes colas de dire si roland
garros et de la beauté
allah allah comme je la relaye à rennes
lundi à la vie qu'elle a pas faire un
régime pour la france mais pour sentir
mieux et donc la conséquence de glam
hasard menteuse non non non si c'est pas
bien dans sa peau bien avec un surpoids
est pas bien sûr jamais dit que les fans
qui étaient différentes et bepa belle si
c'est ce que vous avez à son la réalité
est intérieure voilà en tout cas en tout
cas des autres